I was quite ill for a very long time I
was diagnosed with juvenile rheumatoid
arthritis when I was seven I had major
depressive disorder which was far more
crippling than the arthritis and I think
one of the ways I was able to kind of
claw my way out of feeling sorry for
what myself was because I was lucky
enough to have my dad as a dad he taught
me and he literally told me this in
grade two when I was diagnosed never use
your illness as an excuse and I think
that allowed me to figure out how to get
out of that and get better and I think
using things as an excuse just doesn't
help you get out of it right you just
end up in this puddle of self-pity and
it doesn't improve your life